[Música]
bueno buenas tardes hace mucho tiempo
una niña crecía en un pueblito
agricultor de san ramón de alajuela y
soñaba con poder estudiar el mar con
poder hacer algo por el mar pero
conforme iba creciendo ese sueño se
hacía más y más lejano porque tenía que
encontrar una carrera que la pusiera a
trabajar porque vivía lejos del mar o
por el simple hecho de que soñar da
miedo pero por esas cosas de la vida que
yo llamo destino es que esa niña está
mucho tiempo después bueno tal vez no
tantos años el día de hoy acá y viene a
hablarles del trabajo que realiza en los
océanos y todo empezó en el 2013 cuando
yo tuve la oportunidad de bucear cuando
tuve la oportunidad de sumergirme de
verdad no hay palabras yo creo que esa
vez fue cuando se marcó el antes y
después realmente puedo decir que me
volví a encontrar con esa niña que tenía
un sueño encontré el sueño de nuevo y me
marcaron varias cosas entre esas cosas
estaba el darme cuenta los desconectados
que estamos de los océanos
es como si viviéramos en la tierra pero
en la tierra aislada de algún planeta de
agua y ahora gracias a la ciencia nos
damos cuenta de que dependemos muchísimo
de los océanos sabemos que allí se
produce más del 50 por ciento del
oxígeno que respiramos la función tan
importante que tienen regulando el clima
que si los océanos estaríamos fritos o
simple hecho pensemos en toda la
proteína y alimento que se produce en
estos sitios se sabe que en países con
viajes de desarrollo puede producir
hasta un 50% puede significar un 50%
esto fue lo primero que me marcó y por
supuesto lo segundo que me marcó fue la
vida marina realmente fue darme cuenta
de fue esto siempre ha estado aquí y yo
personalmente yo me enamoré de los
arrecifes de coral de los corales y les
voy a contar por qué los corales además
de ser lo mejor que van a conocer en la
vida son demasiado interesantes
realmente uno los ves simples todo
empieza con un animal que mide
milímetros
en el fondo y es una boca rodeada de
tentáculos es familia de las anémonas de
las medusas por ejemplo y empieza a
crear clones de sí mismos en el fondo y
empieza a extender su tejido a
calcificar pero lo más interesante es
todas estas adaptaciones que ha tenido a
través del tiempo para ser tan exitosos
al día de hoy unos de estas razones por
los cuales son tan exitosos es porque
han establecido simbiosis o
colaboraciones con otros organismos que
les ayudan a sobrevivir por ejemplo hay
una relación que es la que más se conoce
con una microalga esta microalga se
llama sos ante la las algas viven en su
tejido y son los responsables de que
cuando vamos a un arrecife veamos muchos
colores por ejemplo o esta alga también
cuando realiza la fotosíntesis produce
alimento alimento que luego el pólipo o
el coral utiliza y transforma en energía
para reproducirse para calcificar o
también para competir por espacio en el
fondo y ellos son los responsables de
que después de cientos millones de años
veamos los sistemas marinos vivientes
más grandes del planeta como puede ser
la gran barrera del coral que puede ser
vista incluso desde el espacio sabemos
al día de hoy que son clave para la vida
marina que puede albergar
aproximadamente un 25 por ciento de la
vida marina pero pensemos en cuánta vida
depende de este 25% las cifras suben o
pensemos la importancia que tiene
protegiendo nuestras costas o en
actividades como la pesca y el turismo
pero a pesar de ser ecosistemas tan
importantes están en peligro sabemos que
en las últimas décadas
estos ecosistemas los hemos perdido a un
40 por ciento a nivel mundial y también
sabemos que lo que queda el 90% está en
peligro de desaparecer tenemos problemas
muchos problemas afectando los podemos
hablar de algunos globales como el
cambio climático o podemos hablar de
otros más locales como la sedimentación
como la contaminación por agroquímicos
como malas prácticas cuando visitamos
los arrecifes coralinos o un desarrollo
costero mal planificado pero mi idea no
es que nos vayamos pesimistas de aquí al
contrario nieva es que nosotros seamos
conscientes tenemos una realidad y
tenemos que hacer algo y somos agentes
de cambio y hay buenos ejemplos de que
si nosotros nos lo proponemos lo
probemos lo podemos lograr y costa rica
es un ejemplo de esto con una américa
latina se estaban registrando las tasas
de deforestación más altas
costa rica registrada de las tasas de
reforestación más altas nosotros
llegamos incluso recuperar un 50 por
ciento de los bosques que habíamos
solo que ahora necesitamos voltear la
vista a ese 92% del territorio nacional
ahora los ecosistemas en peligro están
en el mar y la biodiversidad que alberga
sólo es comparable con la
responsabilidad que tenemos de
conservarla y de usarla adecuadamente
porque costa rica no es la excepción
tenemos sitios que gracias a la
investigación cuando empezaba en 1980 en
costa rica habían sitios que tenía una
cobertura de un 90 100 por ciento de
coral vivo y ahorita lo que tenemos es
un 25 por ciento de coral view que pasó
y cuando yo estuve ahí
cuando estaba aprendiendo a bucear tuve
la oportunidad de estar en uno de estos
sitios y fue ahí donde yo dije como yo
quiero hacer algo pero al mismo tiempo
es que puedo hacer yo pero de igual
manera decidí hacer algo y fue cuando en
el 2015 tuve la oportunidad de entrar a
una maestría marino costera en la
universidad de costa rica y claro que
esto se convirtió en una oportunidad
para poder estudiar para poder
investigar
y empecé a trabajar mi tesis en
restauración de arrecifes coralinos
realmente lo que nosotros buscamos con
la restauración de arrecifes coralinos
es muy similar piensen en la
restauración en tierra nosotros
trabajamos desde hace tres años
empezamos en el golfo dulce trabajando
con viveros bajo el agua donde lo que
nosotros buscamos es acelerar el
crecimiento que naturalmente podrían
tener los corales si no estuvieran todos
estos factores impidiéndolo y nosotros
buscamos entonces estar ahí para el
ecosistema asistirlo entonces con estos
viveros también que es lo que hacemos
damos condiciones en lo que lo único que
nosotros queremos que los corales hagan
es preocuparse por querer por crecer y
entonces obviamente yo todo el trabajo
que hemos hecho en
y restauración de arrecifes coralinos no
lo he hecho yo sola lo he hecho con un
equipo y les puedo decir que el éxito
del trabajo que hemos realizado y que
hoy les vengo a contar es gracias al
trabajo en equipo y gracias también a
todo este trabajo que hemos realizado
que les comentaba es que hemos creado
una organización que se llama racing
coral costa rica que trabaja de la mano
con el centro de investigación en
ciencias del mar y limnología de la
universidad de costa rica pero tampoco
quiero quitarle mérito dos ayudantes que
hemos tenido desde el inicio ángel y ha
cortes que de verdad desde la primera
vez que nosotros empezamos a trabajar en
el golfo dulce han estado ahí
ayudándonos nos ayudan a darle
mantenimiento nosotros desde hace tres
años vamos todos los meses a los viveros
a dar mantenimiento y a medir
crecimiento y sobrevivencia al día de
hoy hemos trabajado con aproximadamente
seis especies que por supuesto son las
principales formadores de recife
coralinas del área
y las técnicas que nosotros vamos a
utilizar depende en gran medida de cómo
crees el coral hay corales que crecen de
forma ramificada entonces adaptamos
técnicas a esto o hay otros que crecen
masivos o incrustantes y necesitan una
superficie donde crecer entonces
adaptamos técnicas a esto también y
sabemos que tenemos la capacidad de
acelerar o estimular el crecimiento de
los corales y en eso es lo que hemos
estado trabajando después de un tiempo
de que los corales están en los viveros
es cuando están listos para ser llevados
al arrecife que es cuando hablamos de
restauración algo que naturalmente
podría durar 23 años o incluso hasta 5
años si las condiciones están muy mal
nosotros estamos logrando acelerar ese
crecimiento en 9 ó 12 meses
piensen en eso de algo que podría durar
3 o 5 años está durando un año
y esto es uno de los principales logros
que hemos tenido el día de hoy cuando
movemos los corales al arrecife también
trabajamos con diferentes técnicas
queremos asegurar la sobrevivencia de
estos corales y acelerar su crecimiento
también ahí y entonces ya sabemos cómo
cultivar los corales ya sabemos cómo
llevarlos al arrecife y es por eso que
estamos trabajando en una campaña que se
llama 1000 corales por costa rica que lo
que busca lo primero que busca es
divulgar necesitamos que costa rica sea
propia de esta idea ese es nuestro mar y
estos son nuestros arrecifes de coral y
la segunda es tener la capacidad de
cultivar estos mil corales para luego
llevarlos al arrecife no podemos
reforestar un bosque con dos o tres
árboles por eso como mínimo pusimos 1000
corales además de eso nos dimos cuenta
de que no trabajamos en un ecosistema
aislado o sea estamos trabajando en el
golfo dulce para los arrecifes de ahí no
están aislados en el pacífico de costa
rica ni el pacífico de costa rica está
aislado en la región pacífico tropical
oriental y entonces hace pocos meses
lideramos la creación de una red de
restauración con él
en el pacífico tropical oriental con
participantes de mexico de colombia el
salvador y por supuesto costa rica en
donde lo que buscamos es establecer
estas alianzas y fortalecer las que les
ha funcionado a ustedes que nos ha
funcionado a nosotros no perdamos tiempo
y trabajemos a escala recordemos esto
que es demasiado importante y otra de
las cosas más valiosas que hemos
aprendido es que nos hemos convertido en
esa simbiosis una simbiosis entre
humanos y corales es decir nosotros así
como el coral necesita esa micro alga
para que produzca alimento y luego la
convierta en energía
ahora nos necesita nosotros o tal vez
nosotros tenemos que estar ahí porque
nosotros somos los interesados de tener
arrecifes de coral en unas décadas y si
lo pensamos bien restaurar el corazón
del océano o restaurar ecosistemas
naturales depende de que nosotros
podamos crear simbiosis simbiosis con la
naturaleza crear simbiosis entre
nosotros mismos tenemos que complementar
nuestras fortalezas
y para mí el corazón del océano tiene
forma de coral y yo un día soñaba con
poder hacer algo por los arrecifes
coralinos y hoy ya llevo tres años
investigando la mejor manera de hacerlo
feliz día mundial de los océanos
[Aplausos]
[Música]